don't forget to party and drink Bacardi
like that today we will be building
drunk versus high pretty much see if we
still have the same abilities as we did
your kids years the five-minute timer
and we're just gonna do we're just gonna
build stuff let's do it we're
intoxicated that's done but we have to
build this beautiful shark it's a three
and one balloon to the one because we're
kind of too messed up for that I was
also saying I'm gonna need help opening
this box whoever builds the most of it
wins that's it
I have nails I have fake nails I got
these I don't come back on homie assist
I already broke a nail guys perfect
thank you so much okay well that's all
out the window okay already confused but
enrolling with it okay I'm nails I feel
I should get a path so I have the little
circular and then it wants the flat top
the [ __ ] I don't see her bra where is
she where you at were you you just gotta
find this one it's in the second big bag
I put the second bigness in here see
this is the one with the little huh get
you a friend like DJ who only got your
back at this point in the game are we
alive DJ ah first of all I thought we
were doing the beat not a little skinny
where you gotta like make the collection
and then just our 30 years I didn't know
we do all that that's like every oh I
did the wrong way
no I didn't we're good you're so good no
I didn't do the wrong way how I put this
in the thing
putting it together putting it to actual
gather I've found the piece that's a
little mental wedding comes very hot
under these lights it's like a little
thing oh yeah two and a half minutes
oh man oh I'm not gonna get far I'm not
gonna get flat getting far I just got
the two things together okay screaming I
thought my lungs cuz I'm so confused
okay it's a five three minutes against
instant - and I am okay with myself
where are these weird wings other in
here okay whatever I'm just gonna make
one I don't really have a strategy I'm
just kind of following the directions as
best as I can
okay I'm finally on step three right now
I'm looking for square I'm looking for a
square - no I don't need another circle
actually where's my circle there's a lot
of circle action in this there's a lot
of circle action in this can i oh yeah
oh wow so this is the first part it's
like a little fish and then you have to
build a big one to chase after it I
think you I don't mess up I hate you cuz
you're still ahead and I'm literally on
step for it I'm on step two of the new
one so I don't even know what Wow so you
went to the next page mother's knock
yeah I went through eight steps yes Wow
okay well I've already accepted defeat
but I'm still keep going because of bad
never get never gives up even if there's
nothing left there's always something
left
there's always friends that really
promote you
oh man whoo bonnet
oh no fast here you do got one step four
of this other one I have no idea what
I'm doing
I'm using this more syrupy from that hat
we never really gave a chance to create
stuff on our own you know I missed this
that's for sure a little just needs some
expression it's hot it is so hot like I
feel like people don't know one minute
whatever I feel honey oh I messed up I
missed a whole step I just glaze right
about what happens when we talk we
always really take away too long
I go from two minutes or 45 minutes I'm
not mad
okay mean these it TJ you know what no
matter what happened
same here we're all kind of just on
autopilot on we're all on autopilot and
maybe in life you just got a beat on you
don't got to be anything but what you
need to be and he's way ahead of me
right now so I'm just gonna stay here in
these 30 seconds and understand the true
meaning of life is happiness that we can
find for ourselves love it's a very real
moment no I got to step 6 of almost to 8
but at that point I did the first little
fishie which was like a little bonus
build and then I got to step 8 out of
like 60 something so I guess I really
wasn't that fast but DJ why I had to win
one yeah definitely but if I was Josh I
want to give myself five minutes I
probably give myself like an hour and a
half
yeah yeah I did I what I want to see how
fast I could do it yeah fun though it
was definitely fun I'd do it again for
sure I'd do it again for sure we gotta
do
next time we have a party here please
for sure
[Music]
you
[Music]